chances are if you've been playing no
man Scott you've come across a bunch of
locked doors crates and debris that all
asked for a mysterious Atlas pass I
managed to snag one so let me give you
the lowdown on how to get your own
when you're done cataloging abominations
and maxing out your inventory planetside
jump in your ship and head to orbit
initiate a scan and if you're met with a
marker for a space anomaly boost toward
the small moon ask Space Station once
inside you'll be greeted by one half of
Daft Punk and my homie a geek don't
worry if you've been neglecting monolith
visits the duo will communicate in your
native language
the corvax will offer you three options
depending on what path you've chosen but
the GAC is the one you'll need to
impress if you want an a-plus pass
blueprint polo will ask you for data on
the life-forms you've met so far if
you're above level 3 in alien colonists
encounters you'll be rewarded with an
atlas pass level 1 blueprint also behind
polo is a multi-tool that is worth
grabbing if you've got the credits the
pass is a craftable item that functions
like technology in your EXO suit once
crafted it has infinite uses and will
allow you access to all a plus past
locks equivalent to your passes level
level 1 doors on Space Station's appear
to have EXO upgrades behind them while
debris and crates on planets have higher
level crafting materials like suspension
fluid and electron vapor
there's also locked doors inside
colonists shelters which I haven't been
able to get a high enough pass to enter
yet now I'm sure this is by no means the
only way to get an Atlas pass I seem to
be the only one in the office so far
who's managed to figure this out so if
you've been able to get one by other
means let me know in the comments or
transmit me the details on Twitter and
for more no man's sky tips news and
montages of weird testicle headed
dinosaurs keep scanning GameSpot